Oops, the spiritual message that broke through when I was alone caused a clear change.
While expanding his field of activity, he continued to perform as energetically as
ever.Among them
, the player killer of the super-famous online game Fantasy Tree
is rumored to be a ghost, and many psychics have given up on this difficult question.
It's something that we have to stop, but it's not something we can handle. The
power of performing arts can't reach the inside of the system
, right?
Repeatedly leveling up and strengthening weapons every day until midnight on this account Using
decoys as bait, the ghosts and layers are enclosed and beaten,
and the twins succeed in
exorcism  I Khan
With this success, the name of the agency became more and more talked
about.When someone called it "Annie who tasted the spiritual message", its name recognition accelerated, and it even
received interviews from magazines.